ouf
le collectif montréalais clé and friends
a le vent dans les voiles
une belle surprise pour le groupe parti
de rien et dont les racines viennent
d'ailleurs on faisait beaucoup de
spectacle dans la rue en fait ça
s'appelle du bosquet c'est comme jouer
même écho de l'argent cette macédoine
festive 2,5 de soul de jazz de reggae et
de hip hop a d'abord résonne il ya cinq
ans dans les rues de new york avec adèle
au micro et mike clés à la guitare on
s'est même déplacé jusqu'à brooklyn
pendant quelques mots ne louez un
appartement qui ont dû payer à l'avant
ce qu'on a remboursé à coût de 1 $ clé
en france compte aujourd'hui cinq
musiciens de différentes origines réunis
par la passion de la musique de
l'algérie l'egypte le maghreb est
présent télé-québec te laisses des
mélanges académique
ce trio c'est cette espèce de fusion en
équipements les récents succès de clés
et ses amis sont en partie dus à leur
énergie contagieuse issus de la rue à la
scène
ils sont aujourd'hui installés dans un
appartement reconverti en studio où
l'album la musica popular de valdonne a
été produit on a des commandes studio
professionnel même si on est dans un
studio atypique dans un studio à verdun
la musica populaire devait donner tant
inspiré directement de la musica
populaire du brésil qui était un
mouvement musical au brésil dans les
années 60 après avoir donné une
soixantaine de spectacles en europe et
dans de nombreux festivals au québec
klein france fera une dizaine de
représentations au cours des prochaines
semaines
un album entièrement en français devrait
voir le jour à l'automne dans ma cité
comme un site e bon moi je tout séduit
si julie jasmin boudreau radio-canada à
montréal